[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello, everyone, and thanks for
attending the first ever Google
Genomics webinar.
My name is Sri, I'm the Business
Head for Google Genomics,
and today I'll be
walking you through some
of the key features, benefits,
and some cool example
applications of the
genomics platform
that we are very
actively developing.
It is fairly common knowledge
now that sequencing cost has
been plummeting, much
faster than Moore's law,
and the volume of
genomic information
is exploding, as you
can see in this slide.
This trend is not likely
to slow down anytime soon.
Even reasonable
projections estimate
that the amount of genomic
data will double every year,
and will hit one exabyte
within the next five years.
If the current trends persist,
we will hit a billion genomes
by 2025.
That's billion with a B.
But having all that
raw data is not useful
unless you're able to extract
clinical meaning from it.
We will need to layer
on this raw data
a variety of analytics,
ranging from data mining,
novel algorithms,
intuitive visualization,
all the way to very
deep machine learning,
to ultimately have patient
and health care impact.
This kind of data
quantity transition
has been seen by Google before.
We have seen it in search,
in video, and also email.
Now, as scientists
scale up their studies,
and begin to query thousands,
and soon, millions of genomes,
you will need to have scalable
technologies for manipulating,
analyzing, and interpreting
enormous data sets,
without the time
or cost of moving
that data from place to place.
And this is where Google
believes it can help.
Google Genomics that is built
on the Google Cloud platform
aims to help the life science
community organize the world's
genomic information, and make
it accessible and useful.
And just to give you some
perspective on Google Cloud
Platform, just a part of
Google's infrastructure,
which supports YouTube,
can handle 300 hours
of video every minute.
And our search,
which returns you
the results in a
quarter of a second,
that search index is over
100 petabytes in size.
Now let's translate
that into genomic terms.
That is the equivalent of raw
data from six whole genome
sequences uploaded to
our servers every minute,
and we can index and search
the equivalent of a million
whole genome
sequences currently.
Now let's talk about policy, and
mounting scientific evidence.
Policy-- There's
increasing recognition
on the importance
of cloud computing
for genomic data analysis, so
much so that in early March
the NIH updated its
genomic data sharing
policy to allow use of public
cloud to store and access
genomic data.
In parallel, there's mounting
evidence in the life science
community that
cloud-based genomic data
analysis is the future.
Recent articles in
"Nature" showcased how much
cheaper, faster, and flexible
cloud computing resources were,
compared to local data centers.
Google Cloud Platform
resources are even
cited as a key public
cloud computing
resource that is
used increasingly
by genomics researchers.
Google Cloud Platform
offers both infrastructure
as a service, and
platform as a service.
However, we also build
a unique genomics API
that powers many
genomic-specific features,
and like a buffet,
you can choose
whether you want to
use our infrastructure
services, platform services, or
genomic-specific features set
that we have built.
We group the key benefits
of Google Genomics
as Store, Process,
Explore, and Share.
Let's talk about
these one by one.
Store- we enable
content-aware storage.
That is, we know that you are
storing A, T, Z's, and C's.
And we have separate
read and variant
stores, that allow a variety
of different functionality.
All of this data can
be accessed by a web
API that is an implementation
on the GA4GH specifications.
We store many different data
sets, like 1000 Genomes,
Platinum Genomes, as well
as reference sequences
for your analysis.
I will also talk soon about
a couple of large data sets
that are stored on
Google Genomics.
Let's move on to Process.
We allow running of data
processing pipelines
to analyze public or
private genomic data stored
on Google Genomics.
In addition, we inked a deal
with the Broad Institute
recently to bring
the popular GATK
pipeline as a service in
a cloud-optimized format.
Moving on to Explore.
We enable tertiary analysis of
genomic data using a variety
of tools for research purposes.
We enable usage of
Google-scale tools
like BigQuery, that
allow real time analysis
of massive volumes of data.
Moving on to Share.
We enable sharing of these data
sets painlessly, yet securely,
with fine grained access
control, two factor
authentication, client
keys, security at rest
and at transit.
And security is paramount to us.
We sign BAAs that
ensure our platform
supports our customer's HIPAA
compliance requirements.
We also have a variety of
security certifications,
and some of the highest
security encryption
standards in the industry, to
ensure that your sensitive data
stays safe.
Now let's get a little bit
into the details of how
Google Genomics actually works.
The sequence data
from the sequencer
can be stored in a variety
of different file formats,
such as FASTQ, BAM, or
VCFs on Google Cloud.
It is then copied from Google
Cloud to Google Genomics
into the read or
variant store, at which
stage we know its
genetic information.
The API calls can then be made
to make a variety of queries
or analysis on this data.
If you want to do further
tertiary analysis,
we also enable
specific data cohorts
to be exported to BigQuery
for further analysis.
The interesting
thing to note here
is that we enable users of
varying levels of expertise
to access and analyze this data.
If you're an expert
programmer, you can write code.
If you're a wet
lab scientist, you
can use a web UI to write
simple SQL TypeScripts.
If you're a
bioinformatic scientist,
and your favorite tool is
RStudio or iPython Notebook,
you can directly make API
calls from your tool of choice.
I'd like to provide a few
examples that illustrate
these various benefits.
We will start with walking
through the Autism Speaks data
set, and then move on to the
National Cancer Institute's
TCGA data set.
Autism Speaks is one of the
largest nonprofits focusing
on autism-related research.
As you can see, there is
overwhelming evidence now
that there's a genetic basis to
the autism spectrum disorders.
To understand this
genetic basis,
Autism Speaks has launched
an ambitious project
to sequence 10,000
persons, ranging
from children with autism,
affected as well as unaffected
siblings, and parents.
This entire data set is
going to be made available
on Google Genomics for
qualified researchers,
and when completed, will
be over a petabyte in size.
This data set stores genomic
data, ranging from raw reads
to the variants, as
well as phenomic data,
such as diagnosis result,
demographic info, family info,
and a few other
pertinent metadata.
We already have about 1,700
whole genome sequences
and associated phenomic data for
researchers to start analyzing.
Autism Speaks also built a web
portal to host its database,
to allow interactive
querying of the data set.
This allows
non-bioinformaticians to easily
query and explore
interesting data cohorts.
Now let's talk about
a second valuable data
set, which is the National
Cancer Institute's TCGA data
set.
Google Genomics is involved in
two of the three winning bids
for NCI's Cancer Cloud pilot.
Both the open access
TCGA data, as well as
the controlled access data,
requiring dbGaP authorization,
will be hosted on
Google Genomics.
And just like Autism Speaks,
ISB is developing a web research
portal to allow users to
explore the TCGA data set
and select pertinent
cohorts of interest,
and open it directly
into an iPython notebook
to continue their analysis.
Switching gears,
we will now focus
on the Process and Explore
aspects of our platform.
For analysis, we will briefly
review Broad's GATK processing
pipeline.
We will then look at the
open source code examples
that we have made
available on GitHub.
And we will wrap
up with BigQuery
doing powerful analysis
on genomic data.
Let's talk about
the first example.
Google Genomics recently
announced a partnership
with the Broad Institute
that combines their genomics
expertise with Google's
engineering expertise
to help address complex
biological questions.
A key initial foray in this, is
to bring the widely used GATK
pipeline as a service
on Google Genomics.
This enables users to not have
to worry about infrastructure,
or platform, or
license, and simply
focus on running that
pipeline on their data.
Now let's talk about
BigQuery, which
was a powerful Google-scale
tool built originally
to interrogate very large
internet log files, containing
billions of entries.
Turns out, this is
very well suited
for querying genomic data
for tertiary analysis needs.
In this block,
BigQuery is being shown
to do a count and a plot of
all the variants with single R2
alleles on the 1000
Genome data set.
As you can imagine, this is a
fairly heavy-duty calculation,
and this query processes
a terabyte of data,
and provides a result
in 7.4 seconds.
This type of rapid
querying was not
previously feasible
without using
such powerful
Google-scale tools.
This makes research interactive
and real-time, resulting
in accelerated innovation.
Finally, Google and
the research community
are building a growing
repository of open source codes
and tools that are available
on GitHub for researchers.
They can use it for
their own pipelines
or modify it for their analysis.
Listed here is a subset of
some of these tools, which
you will find valuable, and
I'll show two of these examples
now for you.
Shown here is an example of
principal coordinate analysis
code that we have made
available on GitHub.
When we run this PCA analysis on
the entire 1000 Genome data set
and color code the
resulting scatter
plot by population type,
we get a nice clustering
by ethnicity as expected.
Here's an example of code
created by Stanford University
researchers, also
available on GitHub.
This is used to perform quality
control on genomic data sets.
This code specifically
plots heterozygocity rate
on the X chromosome
that helps easily
identify mislabeled
samples, shown
in blue dots towards
the top of the graph.
We hope to continuously
improve this code set
and increase the
ecosystem of valuable code
that users can pull
from on our GitHub page.
Like the Autism Speaks
and the TCGA data set,
we welcome interest
from the community
to host valuable data
sets on Google Genomics.
Similarly, like GATK, we
welcome your analytics pipelines
to be hosted and shared on
Google Genomics as well.
And that brings us to the
conclusion of this webinar.
We hope that you have a
good understanding of Google
Genomics platform,
and how it can really
help you store,
process, explore,
and share genomic information.
For more information, please
visit our website listed here.
Thank you so much.